it's the latest coronavirus controversy
should we all be wearing one of these
since the start of the outbreak
government scientists have advised
against it some researchers say they
should be normal in all sorts of venues
anywhere where there's a lot of people
gathered together in a small space so
the obvious example is a tube train or
bus if people are going back to the
workplace certainly you should be
wearing one then supermarkets are
another example so we're trying to avoid
going into spaces where there's a lot of
people but if we can't avoid it we
should certainly be wearing a face
covering the government says it's
following the science and it's not clear
a face covering will prevent to wear are
getting the disease the Mayor of London
says that's not the right way to think
about it what it does do is stop you
past in on the virus if you're pre
symptomatic or asymptomatic
what we need to do is reduce the cost of
the forest that's why I'm lobbying the
government's expert has changed the
advice and the government to change
their Guardians in London today there
were plenty of masks on show although
still only for a minority this question
is less about science and more about
probability because even if the science
says the effectiveness of Mars is quite
small in a big city it can still make a
very big difference
the huge element of uncertainty is us
will we wear masks properly or as some
fear get a false sense of security about
social distancing we need people to
understand that this isn't the absolute
measure we need to also continue with
our social distancing and we also need
to continue with our regular timetabled
hand-washing so just because you wear a
mask
it doesn't mean now all these well masks
should only be used by healthcare
workers caretakers or by people who are
sick with symptoms of fever and cough
the World Health Organization doesn't
recommend facial coverings for anyone
without symptoms although it is looking
at the situation
so is the UK government while the end of
the lockdown will bring freedom
it may well come with other restrictions
not least what we were to go out burn
amantha Sky News